Hey, welcome to the 360 Live Pre-show.
Conan O'Brien here.
And this is cool.
You are inside my personal office at Warner Brothers.
This is where the magic happens.
And by magic,
I mean this is where I sit when I'm depressed
and hate myself for huge periods of time before the show.
Let me show you around.
It's pretty cool.
We've got a nice office here.
Here's my door.
I have an old typewriter
and I typed Lincoln's Gettysburg Address
on it a couple years ago
and put it up.
One of the greatest speeches of all time.
And then I pretended to sign it,
"A. Lincoln."
People get impressed,
but it's not Lincoln's signature.
It's mine.
I got some cool mementos here.
Some really nice letters from people
that have worked with me.
Look at this.
Isn't this cool?
This is something Andy Richter gave me.
It shows you the skeleton of the Pillsbury Doughboy.
Isn't that cool?
He gave that to me like five years ago,
and I absolutely love it.
I've never looked at the Pillsbury Doughboy
the same way again.
I've got some Jameson's here.
I don't drink hard alcohol,
but I like having it so I look like
a sort of tough guy.
This is my podium right here
where I go over monologue jokes,
or go over scripts during the day.
These are various little solutions
that I spray on my glasses.
This is my Blue Cross/Blue Shield health card.
Oh, here's something cool.
Forget that happened.
This is a button.
Check this out.
This is really cool.
This automatically closes the door.
I love this.
Hey, Sona, could I talk to you for a second?
Sona?
That's my assistant, Sona.
I uh.
Oh, forget it.
It gets me every time.
All right, here's a cool phone
that I got when I was in Armenia with Sona.
We did an Armenia travel show,
and I bought this phone when I was there.
And it's got Russian lettering on it
'cause, of course, Russia controlled Armenia back then.
Here are some boots I got on my Mexico trip
from former President, Vicente Fox.
No, f-ing wall.
Referring, of course, to Trump's proposed border wall.
And these are cool boots.
I've got a bust of John F. Kennedy there.
Another Irishman from Brookline, Massachusetts.
I love my American Presidents.
There's Harry S. Truman.
Personally signed by Harry S. Truman.
There's my California Republic flag.
Right here.
This is where we write down who's gonna
be on the show this week and what comedy's planned.
As you can see,
we're havin' a little bit of a rough patch right now.
Just kidding.
This is a dark week,
so that's why that's clear.
A fan made this.
You may have seen this before.
Made it completely out of scrap metal.
It's a little Conan.
One of the most creative things I've ever seen.
Andrew Smith made this.
Shout out to Andrew Smith.
That's absolutely beautiful,
and actually what my real skeleton looks like.
I've got.
This is cool.
This is uh,
the pins from last year's Comic Con.
Someone put these in plastic and gave 'em to me.
And so I keep those.
This is a map of the United States.
And then, of course,
a map of the world.
Most evil people, like myself,
love a map of the world.
Stalin had one.
Just pretty much anyone who wants
to take over the world has maps of the world.
That's me.
And I wanna spread my form of comedy
throughout the region.
Takes us back to this area right here.
This is a quick check.
Look at this.
This is a lot of Pedialyte.
A couple days ago,
I was vomiting violently
because of stomach bug,
and I had them go get me Pedialyte.
I said, "Sona!
"Get me some Pedialyte."
She bought me like nine giant bottles of Pedialyte.
I had to get through the show.
It wasn't easy.
But I got through the show.
Didn't vomit once,
but I had a bucket under the desk in case I had to.
That's the kind of dedication I have.
And I love this right here.
Also got this in Armenia.
It's an old Russian like
way of telling what day and date it is.
I love,
I just love stuff like this, you know?
Simple.
Low tech.
This was the original Apple Watch.
When they first came out with it,
this is what it looked like.
And uh oh.
I think that I'm outta time.
Someone's trying to get in here.
Pretty much, that's my office.
Hope you enjoyed it.
360.
Techno.
Yo yo.
Tupac.
I don't know.
Peace, out.